ستتعزز فحلف شمال الاطلسي قرر ارسال قوه
العمليات الاحتياطيه لغرب البلقان الى
كوسوفو وثمت ايضا كتيبه احتياطيه جاهزه
لتتحرك الى هناك في ظرف اسبوع
هكذا يتفاعل النيتو اذا مع اضطرابات
الشماليه كوسوفو الاخيره
تلك التي اصيب فيها عشرات من افراد قوات
حفظ السلام الدوليه التي يقودها الحلف
ندين بشده هذه الاعتداءات غير المبرره ضد
قوات حفظ السلام التابعه للنيتو في شمال
كوسوفو والتي ادت الى اصابه نحو 30 جنديا
مثل هذه الهجمات غير مقبوله ويجب ان تتوقف
يتصدر الاوروبيون الاصوات الداعيه للتهدئه
بين سلطات بريشنا والمحتجين من الاقليه
الصربيه
يريدها مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه والابنيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي تهدئه دون قيد او شرط
يقول جوزيف بوريل انه يتوقع من سلطات
كوسوفو ان تخرج قوات الشرطه من محيط
البلديات في الشمال كخطوه اولى
حتى يهدا الموقف تريد روسيا من جانبها من
الغرب شيئا اخر اي يتوقف عما تعتبره
استفزازا لصربيه وتاثيرا في سلوك سلطات
لا يتوانى عن اتهام قوات حلف شمال الاطلسي
بوجه خاص بانها عامل تصعيد تدافع القوه
الدوليه عن مهمتها التي تتلخص في الوقت
الراهن كما تقول في منع مزيد من التدهور
في الموقف
محيط مبنى بلديه
حيث تعزز القوه مواقعها ما زال وموقعان
اخران ملتقى للمحتجين الصرب على تنصيب
رؤساء بلديات جدد من القوميه الالبانيه
هم بذلك يرفضون نتائج انتخابات قاطعوها
الشهر الماضي في مناطق تمركزهم وشهدت نسبه
مشاركه متدنيه
تدعم طرحهم فهي تدفع نحو اقامه رابطه
بلديه صربيه في شمال كوسوفو بعد الاحداث
الاخيره وضع مجلس امنها الجيش في حاله
تاهب قصوى وامره بالتحرك نحو الحدود
اما الرئيس الصربي فيطالب بالانسحاب
العاجل لمن سماهم رؤساء البلديات المزيفين
وافراد قوات الشرطه الخاصه من عاصمة
كوسوفو
وقصفوا التي لا تعترف بها صربيا دوله
مستقله فوضتها قبل شهور برعايه امريكيه
واوروبيه الهدف كان الاتفاق على مسار
لتطبيع العلاقات بين بريشنا